[Musique]
les intentions ne suffiront pas on peut
décréter les réformes mais pas leurs
résultats une nécessité tant de choc
qu'on meurtrit le pays choc structurel
de la démondialisation choc
conjoncturelle énergétique
inflationniste
ose des taux d'intérêt et de la charge
de la dette publique comme privé à qui
la faute au marché ou à l'état et sa
bureaucratie quelle solution une
intervention de l'État ou plus de
liberté pour le marché c'est aux
politiques que revient le choix des
armes et des réformes Emmanuel Macron
classé centriste a déjà déclenché des
réformes qui penchent à droite réforme
de l'assurance chômage ou qui penche à
gauche avec le bouclier anti-inflation
néanmoins pour l'analyse politique ou
économique le politique décide toujours
sous contrainte une correction des
déséquilibres économiques imposent de
cibler entre des perdants qui financent
la mesure et des gagnants qui en
profiteront mais pour financer
l'augmentation de ces dépenses publiques
déjà insoutenables à 57% du PIB sans
augmenter aujourd'hui les impôts on va
creuser le déficit et avec lui la dette
publique que des générations futures
devront assumer
pour l'heure quelques pistes ont été
dévoilées par Emmanuel Macron loi
travail déclinée dans un grand chantier
pouvoir d'achat parce que l'inflation et
le sujet numéro 1 qui attise la colère
de la rue pas de réformes ici mais
mettre chacun face à ses responsabilités
consultation des partenaires sociaux
patronat et syndicats peuvent aussi
s'entendre comme ils l'ont démontré lors
de la Corse sur le partage de la valeur
mais on peut souligner un paradoxe ici
d'une situation budgétaire quasi
insoutenable comme le démontre la Cour
des comptes qui plaide plutôt
implicitement pour une politique de
rigueur tandis que le politique fantasme
sur la lutte contre l'inflation comme
plus facilement négociable car aussi
délégable au risque d'une boucle prix
salaire infinie contre-productive
s'agissant des réformes structurelles de
long terme l'État semble s'engager
explicitement dans une réforme de
réindustrialisation pour une industrie
verte il devra aussi s'inquiéter de
l'hôpital la justice l'éducation les
transports mais il lui faudra alors
prendre la vraie mesure du coût
bureaucratique
usé de medgemar K pour améliorer la
performance des services publics et plus
tard peut-être reste les marqueurs pour
l'histoire loi immigration comptant sur
l'apport des voies de LR ou encore la
réforme des institutions
réformer n'est pas si simple
paradoxalement la paix sociale s'obtient
par des réformes consensuelles mais
elles sont aussi peu agissantes à la
correction des déséquilibres tandis
qu'il est impossible de guérir
l'économie sans la brutalité de réforme
structurelles fortes vraie dilemme car
lorsque les tailles fort et nous
oppressent lorsqu'il est faible nous
périssons disait Paul Valéry la mère des
réformes ne passerait-elle pas alors par
an audit généralisé du fonctionnement de
l'État aux politiques de relever les
défis réveiller cette puissance endormie
qu'elle a France engageant des actions
dans un volontarisme politique hors de
tout calcul électoraliste et d'observer
parfois que ce qui est salutaire à la
nation ne va pas semblable dans
l'opinion ni sans perte dans l'élection
telles étaient les dernières phrases du
général de Gaulle dans mémoire d'espoir
[Musique]